- Packing the Supreme Court
isn't unconstitutional.
Congress does have that power,
but packing it with
this intention in mind
under this circumstance
really is anti-Constitutional.
It would undermine the
separation of power,
not as a bug, but as a feature.
And that's what
makes it so wrong.
(calming music)
- I'm Dave Rubin
and joining me today
is the Senior Senator from
the great state of Utah,
and the author of the new book,
Saving Nine: The Fight Against
the Left's Audacious Plan
to Pack the Supreme Court
and Destroy American Liberty.
Senator Mike Lee, finally
welcome to The Rubin Report.
- Thank you very much.
It's good to be with you.
- Well, you have
handed me an awful lot,
that I'm talking
an awful lot about
in the title of the new book,
and I wanna focus an
awful lot on that.
But first, what is it like
to be on the short list
of what I would call sane people
in the United States
government right now?
- Yeah, it's sort of like being
one of the tallest buildings
in Tooele, Utah, you might say.
There aren't a lot of
tall buildings there.
- I take it short
buildings over there.
Yeah, I mean, what is going on?
- Yeah so--
- What is going on right
now with the government,
and just the amount of
people that seemingly
are doing nothing or
all of the wrong things?
- Yeah, the problem is
less about doing nothing
and more about doing
all the wrong things.
When people start to think
that God is government,
and when they start to think
that all government
needs to take place
and transpire in Washington, DC,
that's a wicked combination.
A combination we've been
living under for many decades,
but it's reached a
boiling point of late,
and the left wants to
make it a lot worse.
We're here to stop it.
- So that really is in many
ways what the book is about,
and one of the things
that you talk about,
and I've been trying to hit
on for a while on the show,
I have tried and I generally try
not to impune people's motives.
But as you know,
the road to hell
is paved with good intentions.
And it seems to
me at this point,
what we are seeing
out of the left,
and virtually the
entire Democrat Party
is an intentional destruction
of so many of the things
that the founders had
built and had created
to allow us to all live free.
So before we get
into the specifics,
what do you think about
the intentions part?
Do you think a lot of what's
going on is intentional,
or do you think it's confusion
or a misunderstanding
of the documents or
something else altogether?
- You know, I tend to believe
that most people on the left
have at least
convinced themselves
that the place they want
to take us is a good place,
that that would be
good for the country.
In the case of packing the
Supreme Court, for example,
I think they somehow believe
that that would take
us to a better place.
Now, I wrote Saving Nine
in order to explain why
the opposite is true.
So, but regardless of
what their intention is,
I have no ability to jump
into someone else's mind,
to read their mind,
to know the inner
thoughts and intentions
of their heart and their
soul and their mind.
But what I do know is certain
things that history tells us,
and history tells us that
there are some mistakes
we ought not want to repeat.
As Mitch McConnell likes to say,
"There's no education in the
second kick from the mule".
We've already been kicked by
the court packing mule once,
I described that at great length
in chapter four of Saving Nine,
we do not want the
education that would come
from the second kick
of that same mule.
- So when you hear your
colleagues across the aisle
talking about packing the court,
and you're hearing
it all the time now,
I mean, it's virtually every
day someone is saying it,
do you ever try to pull
them aside and say,
"Hey, do you guys realize
"that if you pack
the court this time,
"we'll just pack the
court next time?"
Or that perhaps this
is a complete affront
to the separation of powers,
or a series of other things
that you get into in the book,
but you kind of say to them,
"Hey, do you realize what
you're gonna do here,
"even if you temporarily
get what you want."
- Of course, of course.
And you know, for
the time being,
they're content with
talking about it,
but not really doing
it, at least not yet.
I think they're
waiting to do that
perhaps until the Dobbs
ruling is actually issued.
And maybe that's when they
start through it in earnest,
then it gets very, very serious.
But I think you're
right to point that out.
I don't think they
really want to go
where they're trying
to take us either.
If they really think about it,
and I hope they will
read Saving Nine,
because regardless of
whether they agree with me
on any other policy issue,
they ought to be able to agree
that the minute you
rip off that bandaid,
and for reasons I
explain in the book,
the minute you start to
politicize the court formally,
as you would do by increasing
the number of Justices
in order to achieve a
desired political outcome,
there is no stopping it.
The Republicans, who
in modern history,
have never attempted
anything like this
would be compelled
to do the same thing
the next time the shoe
is on the other foot.
That is the next time the
House, and the Senate,
and the White House
are all under the control
of the same party.
If the Democrats
increase by four,
you can see Republicans
increasing it by four more.
Maybe it'll be six next time.
The result of that won't
be pleasant for anyone.
The court, because of the
lifetime appointment guarantee
of Article III of
the Constitution,
this will be a one way ratchet,
and the court will
expand a lot faster
than it could ever shrink.
Before long it won't
look like a court at all,
but like a political body,
and a large one at that.
Eventually it'd look like
the intergalactic Senate
in the Star Wars movie series.
(Dave laughing)
- Believe it or not, I am
a big fan of the prequels.
And I think that they're looking
better and better over time
because of exactly
that, the you know,
how power just flips
depending on who's in charge.
At what point do you think
that packing the court
is actually an assault on
the Constitution itself?
In other words, that
one branch of government
would in essence be destroying
another branch of government.
They're supposed to have
checks and balances.
But to me that's a,
it's almost a violation
of the oath of office
if your goal as a legislator
is to override
what the judiciary
is supposed to be comprised of.
- Yeah no, that's exactly right.
And I think if you're doing it,
the minute you're doing it
not because the court
is short staffed,
I think in theory,
that could be a legitimate
reason to do it.
If at some unknown
point in the future,
there's widespread
consensus that there,
the human resources on the court
have been outpaced
by the caseload,
you could consider
an argument then.
Even then you would
wanna be very careful
what phasing in the increases.
But whereas here,
they're just talking
about a political outcome
that they desire
they want to achieve,
then this is an assault on that.
Here's the interesting
thing about that.
It's kind of an
irony built into it.
Packing the Supreme Court
isn't unconstitutional.
Congress does have that power.
But packing it with
this intention in mind
under this circumstance
really is anti-Constitutional.
It would undermine the
separation of power,
not as a bug, but as a feature,
and that's what
makes it so wrong.
- But do you think
it matters to them?
You know what I mean?
Like they sort of, their
ends justify the means,
so do you think
it really matters,
meaning that they, if they
can go ahead and do it
and get away with it,
which seemingly you can get away
with virtually
anything these days,
then why not go ahead and do it?
I know that's not your position,
but from their perspective.
- From their perspective,
that often is a big motivator,
and I think that is part
of why they're doing it.
Not withstanding
some of these risks,
is that they're
looking at this saying,
if we can do it and it would
please our base, why not do it?
Why not at least try, maybe
we will swing and miss,
but we'll at least draw
a lot of great applause
from our own base.
But for the reasons I explain
in chapter four of Saving Nine,
even when you swing and miss,
even when you threaten
to pack the court,
you propose court packing,
and the legislation fails,
it can leave an indelible mark,
a mark that we're
still paying for,
in the, you know, lengthy
period of time that's elapsed
since 1937 when
they tried it last.
We're still suffering from
what happened to the court,
what it did to the court
all that many years ago.
85 years later, and we're
still paying for that mistake.
- So you write about that
pretty extensively actually.
So can you just go
into what happened
those 85 years ago, yeah.
- 85 years ago, you
had a Supreme Court
that was doing its job and
was enforcing the outer limits
on Congress's authority,
especially its authority
under the Commerce clause.
The part that gives
Congress the power
to regulate trade or commerce
between the states and
the foreign nations.
And FDR, President
Franklin D. Roosevelt
was frustrated at the fact
that the Supreme Court
was knocking down
some of his signature
pieces of legislation,
giving Congress and the
federal government as a whole
unprecedented power
to deal with things
in response to the
Great Depression.
They wanted to be
able to regulate,
things like agriculture,
and mining, and labor,
and manufacturing,
even though historically
those had been regulated
almost exclusively by the states
and not the federal government.
Now, the Supreme Court just
interpreting the Constitution
based on what it had always
meant was threatened by FDR.
Just two years after
the court had moved
into its new building, the
building it now occupies,
on April 12th, 1937,
the Supreme Court effectively
rewrote the Constitution.
It rewrote the Commerce clause
to give the federal
government the power
to regulate anything that even
affected interstate commerce,
not just interstate
commercial transactions,
or the corridors through
which they take place,
but anything that
affects those things
could now be
regulated by Congress.
That meant labor, manufacturing,
agriculture, mining,
all the things that FDR
wanted to be able to
regulate comprehensively
from Washington DC,
they could now do.
This occurred as a result
of one vote switching.
Associate Justice Owen Roberts,
who had previously stood
by others on the court
who had acknowledged
there were limits
on the Congress's
Commerce clause authority,
he switched his vote.
He joined with the
Liberals on the court
and they rewrote
the Constitution.
And it's a result of that,
that we're now dealing
with the federal government
that regulates every
aspect of human existence,
that imposes $2 trillion of
regulatory compliance costs
on the American economy,
that requires Americans
to work for months
out of every year,
just to pay their federal taxes
and then tells them that
even that's not enough
'cause we're $31
trillion in debt.
All of that, and the fact
that most of our laws
at the federal
level are now made
by unelected
unaccountable bureaucrats
that can all be traced
to this switching time
that saved nine,
as I explain in chapter
four of Saving Nine.
- So as a free market
guy, as a capitalist guy,
as a guy that believes
in states' rights,
and you want the free
exchange of goods,
what should we be doing
to maybe get more people?
Well, we can talk about
it and get more people
to know about it and you
can write books about it,
but what can we do
to get that case
to be looked at again, perhaps?
- Well yeah, so first of all,
we need to get people
talking about federalism
and separation of powers,
because that's what we lost
the last time that Democrats
tried to pack the court.
When we get people
talking about that,
we make it part of the
national political discourse.
You shouldn't have
anyone running,
especially as a Republican,
but really from either
party for the US House,
or the US Senate, or the
presidency of the United States,
without them talking
about where they stand
on how to restore federalism,
the vertical protection
that keeps most of the power
at the state local level,
and how to restore
separation of powers,
the horizontal
protection that says
we're gonna have one
branch of government
that makes the laws, Congress,
the legislative branch,
one branch of government
headed by the President,
the executive branch
that enforces the laws,
and another branch that
interprets the laws
headed by the Supreme Court.
Those need to become mainstream
political conversation
topics in America,
again, especially
for federal races.
That is really how we fix this.
But in the meantime, we've
got to also counteract
the clear and present
threat that we face
due to this now trending hashtag
of hashtag expand the court,
pioneered by Elizabeth
Warren and others,
who were trying overtly
to attack the independence
of the federal judiciary.
- So I know we could bash
the progressives and the left
all day long, but it's obviously
not just them that have,
you know, expanded the size of
government, and the budgets,
and all of those things,
and sending money to
all sorts of countries
when we barely have a dime here.
What do you think the
Republicans and Conservatives
could be doing better
in terms of giving some of
the power back to the states
and in terms of reigning
in some of the budgets
and that kind of stuff?
- Yeah no, it's a
fair point you make.
I mean, look, this expansion
of the size, scope, reach,
and cost of the
federal government,
this has occurred
under the direction
of Houses of Representatives,
of Senates and of White Houses
of every conceivable
partisan combination.
The problem is that we've
got the progressive mindset
that permeates the entirety
of the Democratic Party,
and a significant portion
of the Republican Party.
And I think we have to focus
on that as Republicans and say,
look, we're not the
party of progressives,
we're the party of liberty,
we're the party of free markets,
we're the party
of civil society.
All those things atrophied
when we excessively flex
the federal muscle,
and that's what
we've got to undo.
And in that respect, Saving
Nine is about much, much more
than just preserving
the independence of
the Supreme Court
and prohibiting court packing.
It's about restoring federalism
and separation of powers.
This book will teach
you how to do that.
- So you mentioned politics
entering the court.
Obviously at this point,
because politics has become
our national religion,
it seems almost
impossible not to.
I had Judge Napolitano from
Fox on a couple weeks ago
in the middle of the Ketanji
Brown Jackson hearing.
And his position
was that basically
the Senate should confirm
a judge that is a,
you know, nominated
by the President,
barring something
really off the charts,
like really, really
beyond unbelievable
in the decision that they made,
that basically the decision
should be left to the President,
and short of something
really catastrophic
the person should be confirmed.
Now we watch confirmation
hearings and on both sides,
it's all sorts of, you know,
dredging out all kinds
of horrible things
or made up things in the
case of Brett Kavanaugh,
perhaps in Ketanji Brown's case,
the fact that she couldn't
tell you what a woman was,
maybe that was a catastrophic
thing that would've qualified.
But what's your general position
on when a President
nominates someone,
what the process should
actually look like?
- Look, I make no
mystery about the fact
that when there is a
Democratic President in office,
I understand that we're not
gonna get the same nominees
as we would when
there's a Republican
holding the office
of the presidency.
Still, it still matters.
And it still matters
to me to review
each candidate individually
and figure out whether he or
she understands, respects,
appreciates, and will
defiantly protect
the independence
of the judiciary,
and will understand that
each case is to be decided
on the basis of its own merits
and on the basis of
what the law says,
on the basis of the law,
as it was understood at
the time of its enactment,
if a statute or at the
time of its ratification,
if it's a provision
of the Constitution.
And so I'll vote
yes for a nominee,
even if that nominee doesn't
share my political worldview,
if I think that nominee
is sufficiently committed
to the judicial task.
If not, I won't.
So I don't know that
that ought to ever mean
blind deference
to any President,
whether that President
is of your own
political party or not.
It certainly doesn't
mean that to me,
and I don't think it should
to anyone else either.
- You mentioned the Dobbs
case before, you know,
it's kind of bizarre, you
know, this leak happens,
you know, now it's probably
six weeks ago or so,
and basically not only are we
not talking about it anymore,
but it doesn't
seem like anyone's
trying to track down the leaker.
Are you aware of
anything that's going on
that maybe we're not fully
aware of through the media yet?
And what do you think
that, the leak itself,
has done to the
integrity of the court?
- You know, until
fairly recently,
I was convinced that they
had identified the leaker,
and they just had made
a strategic decision
within the court not to
announce the leaker's identity
until after the Dobbs
case was decided,
which may not happen until
the end of the court's term,
which usually wraps
up in the final days
of the month of June.
Now but then a few days ago,
news reports started to surface
suggesting that the
investigation is still ongoing,
that they've asked law clerks,
there are four for each Justice,
to submit their phone records
and submit sworn affidavits
about their conduct
of this in this case
about what, if anything,
they have done with copies
of Supreme Court opinions.
So it seems to be that the
investigation is ongoing.
I do think they'll
figure it out who it is,
'cause we're dealing with a
fairly finite group of people.
And it's not that
hard to figure out,
I think we'll find out.
Whoever it is, if as I
suspect it is a law clerk,
they should never
practice law again.
They should be
disbarred for this.
Because this is handling
sensitive information,
information that was
not theirs to release.
And you know, as a law clerk,
they drill this into you.
It was made clear to me
when I was a law clerk
at the Supreme Court
for Justice Alito,
you don't take draft opinions
out of the building ever.
You don't take it to lunch,
you don't take it home.
It shouldn't even
leave your office
when you're finished with it.
You can't just throw
it in the waste basket,
you've got to put it
in this special bag,
a bag whose contents
are retrieved at the
end of every day,
they retrieve the contents,
they shred the documents,
not just once but twice,
turning it into a confetti.
And then they put it
in an incinerator,
and burn it into
this black powder.
And then they add a
little bit of water to it,
and it creates this tar
like slurry structure
before it ever
leaves the custody
of the Supreme Court
of the United States.
That's how seriously they take
the confidentiality of the
opinion drafting process.
So whoever did this
knows darn well
what those procedures
are and why they matter.
That's why that person
should never be permitted
to practice law again.
I do think they'll
figure it out.
- So assuming they do figure
it out, or even if they don't,
what do you think it's
done just generally
to the integrity of the court,
the ability for the
court to make a decision,
hold a decision until
the time is right
for it to be released,
and just the way the
media reacts to all of it,
because obviously this
was leaked to Politico,
they had their decision on
whether to release it or not,
or verify it in other ways,
from everything we
understand it is legit,
but just the general
standing of the court,
which to me,
the left is constantly
trying to subvert anyway,
not just through packing,
but generally just assault
all of the decisions.
- Yeah, I think
it's devastating.
I think it's devastating.
Like the court has
enjoyed a history
in which this has not occurred.
Now the left wing media is
fond of saying things like,
"Oh, this isn't the first
time this has happened.
"Other leaks have happened."
Yeah sure, every
once in a while,
maybe once or twice in a
decade word will leak out
maybe an hour or two before
an opinion is released
suggesting that the person knows
what the answer is gonna be.
And most of the time it's
a 50-50 guess anyway,
it's like betting on red or
black at the roulette wheel.
You're gonna be right on
average half the time.
And sometimes they
get that right.
But they've never leaked
an entire draft opinion.
This has never happened before.
There's been a network of
trust within the court,
and there's been unanimous
support within the court
and its support staff in making
sure this doesn't happen.
So I think we can stem
the damage moving forward,
as long as the court takes
additional security steps
to make sure this
never happens again.
But I think they're gonna
have to put in place
some sophisticated watermarks
behind every draft
opinion from now on
that will identify
that the person
who had access to that watermark
so that a leak like
this can't happen.
And if it does happen,
the person will be
immediately found.
- So you mentioned
federalism earlier
and states' rights, obviously,
as I mentioned to you
right before we started,
I spent the last eight years
of my life in California.
I now live in the
free state of Florida.
And as I've been
saying on the show,
I genuinely feel like I
live in a different country,
not in a different state,
but in a different country.
I'm wondering what do you
see differently on the ground
in terms of what your
constituents want in Utah,
and the way that you feel
that you can govern there,
versus what goes on
when you show up in DC
and what you have to deal with?
- Yeah, that's a good question.
Look, most Americans,
it's true of Utahans,
and I'm pretty sure it's
true of Californians
and people in
Massachusetts, in Wyoming,
or whatever state
you wanna identify,
most Americans
intuitively resonate
with the concept of federalism.
And by the way, I refer
to it by that title
rather than as states' rights,
'cause my belief is that a
state is a unit of government.
Units of government don't have
rights, they have authority.
Authority is almost the
opposite of a right.
So it's recognizing
the appropriate sphere
of government authority.
That's what federalism is.
And most people understand
that federalism makes sense
because it allows
for more Americans
to gain access to more of the
kind of government they want,
and less of the kind of
government they don't want.
So for instance, in Utah,
it's pretty well understood
that we'd rather not have
a government-funded single
payer healthcare system.
We have enough experiences
going to the post
office or the DMV
to know that we don't want
government being our doctor.
People in Vermont I'm told
would much prefer a single
payer government-funded,
government-run
healthcare system.
If we respected federalism
more completely,
then more states would be able
to do exactly as they want.
Vermont would be able
to go in that direction,
Utahans wouldn't do that.
That's what federalism is
supposed to be all about.
That's why it's protected
in the text of the original
Constitution doubled down on
in the 10th Amendment,
but we've neglected it.
Federalism still
has great potential.
We just have to
allow it to be used.
And for that to happen,
people in Congress
have got to stop pretending
that we are a general
purpose legislative body.
We're supposed to be in charge
of just a few basic things.
National defense, declaring
war, weights and measures,
trademarks, copyrights,
and patents,
bankruptcy laws, regulating
trade or commerce
between the states
with foreign nations
and with the Indian tribes,
and that's about it.
There are a few others, but
there's not much more than that.
Everything else is
supposed to be reserved
for the states and localities.
- You know, it's funny because
I asked you this already,
but when I hear you say that,
and lay it out so cleanly
and clearly and obviously,
it's just like what the
bell in my head goes off of,
I just don't think any Democrat
Senators care about that.
I think a certain amount
of Republicans don't,
but I honestly don't
think that any Democrat,
I cannot name one.
If you can name one,
I'd love to hear it,
but I just don't think
they care about what it is,
what you guys are
supposed to do.
- Yeah, I think that's right.
For two principle
reasons I don't.
Number one, if they can
win, they can win bigly,
as they might be
inclined to put it.
Number two, they are winning
in that they have
federalized everything.
And this is the ultimate
progressive dream
is to consolidate as much
government power as possible,
consolidate it in the
national government.
That way states won't
even have the opportunity
of experimenting with a lower
profile system of government.
Even though they themselves
might like certain
aspects of federalism
in these leftist states,
they can't tolerate the
thought of other states,
states like mine, states
like the state of Utah,
doing it differently.
They don't want the competition,
and they also think that
in order to redeem us,
in order to save
us from ourselves,
we've got to nationalized
all of our law making.
What does that get us?
Well it gets us a whole lot of
contention, it gets us riots,
it gets, it causes us
to create something akin
to an Imperial presidency
in which that people seem to
worship government increasingly
thinking that the bigger,
the government in question,
the better off we all are,
reinforcing the
progressive mindset.
- I thought you were gonna make
a Palpatine reference there.
I felt it coming.
- It could have come, but yeah,
it couldn't quite make it.
- So on something like
the 40 billion to Ukraine
that the Senate just voted on,
obviously your counterpart
there in Utah did vote for it,
Mitt Romney did vote for it.
You know, from my audience's
perspective, for the most part,
it's like, man, we
have so many things
we could be fixing here
if we even have this
money in the first place,
which we kind of don't have,
but we seemingly
always have money
for other people's
problems, not for our own.
How do you kind of deal with
that internal battle of,
again, what you're
dealing with in DC,
and what kind of
the machine wants,
versus what your
own people want,
and for a guy like you, you
actually care about budgets,
and I have a suspicion you know
that the 40 billion
doesn't really exist.
Is that fair to say?
- Yeah, so I looked
at that legislation.
I went through it with
a fine tooth comb,
and what I found were
some significant problems.
Number one, we're dealing
with rampant inflation
in this country.
The people in Utah are
paying an additional $751
each month every month for
their basic living expenses,
relative to what
they were paying
at the beginning
of just last year.
This is a huge
defacto tax increase
that disproportionately harms
the poor and middle
class of my state.
And it's entirely foreseeable,
it is the natural consequence
of excessive federal spending.
And so I thought
that the Ukraine bill
should have been paid for,
should have been offset,
and I introduced an
amendment to that effect
that would've done that.
Also in that same
amendment was language
that would've stripped
out Title V of that bill.
Title V is where the worst
spending abuses within the bill
could be found,
or we're talking a
large amount of money,
about $15 billion or so
that would've gone to activities
in the state department
that are at best, tangentially
related to Ukraine.
And in many instances
have been linked
by this administration itself
to the administration's
radical climate change
fighting agenda.
- So when Rand Paul,
for example, said,
"Hey, we should at least
be able to, you know,
"know where the money's
going, or audit this thing,
"or get some receipts",
and basically the entire
media tried to destroy him
as if you know, he's
in Putin's pocket.
I'm guessing you were
pretty sympathetic
to what he was going through.
- Absolutely, absolutely.
Yeah, the same thing
happened to me.
I mean, the changes
Rand Paul proposed,
let's have an Inspector General
over this, very reasonable.
In fact, it's hard
for me to imagine
that that subset of Americans
who wouldn't want something
like that in place.
Likewise with my bill,
there's nothing that should
be terribly objectionable
about saying we should
offset this spending
so that we reduce the
inflationary pressures
that we're exerting
on the economy.
And as long as
we're passing a bill
that's supposed to
be about Ukraine,
it shouldn't be about
further entrenching
the state department
and just flooding the
state department itself
with additional funds.
- So when you, not to,
I'm not trying to create a fight
with you and your counterpart,
your other Senator in Utah,
but like, did you and
Mitt discuss that?
And did he say, yeah, I'm
just kind of okay with it,
or not even about him,
but just generally
when you spoke
to some other
Republican Senators
that just kind of signed
it and were just like,
ah, we're doing it.
What do people say?
- That's the problem that's
one of my biggest frustrations
with Washington is that
people will sign on to
what I refer to as the sort
of bumper sticker effect
of a particular bill.
And for many of my colleagues,
they looked at this and said,
"Look, Ukraine is important.
"Ukraine is a sympathetic victim
"to a vile menace to
human civilization
"who is Vladimir Putin."
And Vladimir Putin is
in fact, a vile menace,
and Ukraine is a
sympathetic victim here.
But to translate
that into saying,
because I like X,
and X would be covered in one
way or another by this bill,
I must vote for this bill,
causes us to enact
some very bad policies.
It causes us to spend
way too much money,
and it's frankly, one
of the biggest reasons
why we're $31 trillion in debt.
These people are
afraid to be seen
as voting against a
sympathetic beneficiary,
or a combination thereof.
And that's how we
get to this problem.
So it's the basic difference
of opinion that I have
with some of my colleagues,
who will look at
something and say,
"I agree with the
overall objectives,
"so I'm willing to vote for it,
"even though this
particular formulation
"has some serious
problems with it."
- So since you are a guy
that cares about
the actual rules
and the way that we're
supposed to be governed,
I mean, in effect, it seems
like we're at war right now.
I mean, we haven't declared war,
I know the President's
supposed to declare war,
and it has to get authorized
and everything else,
but I mean, when you're
pouring tons of money
into something, when you're
giving people weapons,
et cetera, et cetera, you
in essence are at war.
I mean, at what point do
we start looking at that,
and having Congress or the
Senate go, "Boy, are we at war?
"And how much money do you
have to pour into something
"before you officially
call it war?"
If you keep giving a guy
weapons, maybe it is war.
Or again, is that just
one of those things
that is just kind
of, it is what it is,
and the beat goes on.
- Yeah, I think it's
absolutely essential
that before we
take any more steps
in the direction of warfare,
that we take into account
our role as a Congress
and declaring war.
Over many decades, Congress
has gradually relinquished
its declaration of war powers.
As presidents of both
political parties have asserted
really broad powers attached
to their inherent authority
under Article II as commander
in chief of the armed forces.
This is problematic
because it was one of the
distinguishing characteristics
of the Constitution.
One of the things that
made it very different
than the English model,
the system that we had
just broken away from
allowed the chief executive,
the king, to take us to war.
And then it was up to parliament
to figure out how to pay for it.
Under our system, Federalist
69 makes this very clear
when Alexander Hamilton explains
that it was with good reason
we put the power to declare
war in the first instance
in the hands of Congress,
because that's the branch
most accountable to the people
at the most regular intervals.
So I think if we're gonna
take any additional steps
in this area,
we really ought to have a
conversation about whether,
in what way, to what extent
we wanna be involved in
a conflict with Russia.
Keep in mind, Ukraine spends
less than $5 billion a year
in defense.
Russia spends about $65
billion a year in defense.
If you add up the
previous Ukraine bill,
14 billion to this
Ukraine bill, 40 billion,
you're talking about
more than 10 times
what Ukraine spends on
defense in an entire year
is what we have devoted in
the name of Ukraine defense.
And we're knocking on the door
of what Russia spends
on defense worldwide
in an entire year.
- Do you think we're
in a bizarre situation
as the last superpower
that we're still expected
to do everything,
but maybe we kind of just
can't in a certain respect.
I personally believe that,
I believe in American
exceptionalism,
I believe the world is
better when we're leading,
I believe in peace through
strength, all of those things,
but that maybe right now,
especially with the
leadership that we have,
that we just can't do that
much good at the moment
in these big
international things.
- Well yeah, look,
I think this is where we
get dangerously off course.
I think it is dangerous
for any country,
last standing superpower or not,
to step into the
mindset that says,
"If there is injustice
in the world,
"we can be counted on as the
presumptive police force."
No nation can do that.
No nation can withstand that.
Certainly we can't.
Our Constitutional system should
never allow that to happen.
What really needs to happen
is that anytime we get
involved militarily,
we really ought to have
Congress declaring war
before we take any
action in that direction.
And always the
inquiry should be on
not on whether bad people
are doing bad things
in another part of the world,
but on how that affects
American national security,
the safety, security,
the liberty of the
American people at home.
If we can't connect it to
that, we shouldn't be doing it,
because there is no end to
the threats that we will face,
the battles we
will have to fight
with no real
corresponding ability
to do all of those things.
If our only test
is to go out there
and find bad people
doing bad things,
we'll be very busy,
so busy indeed,
that we will leave the
American people vulnerable
in their own homeland.
- So speaking of safety
and liberty at home,
you know, two years or two
and a half years post COVID,
are you hopeful that
more people have woken up
to some of the
state's right stuff,
some of the stuff related
to the courts, and mandates,
and all of the
overreach that we saw?
I mean, my sense is
that a lot of people
really have woken up.
I don't know if they
got scared again,
if they would just drop
all of their newfound ideas
very quickly in the
name of security,
but I'm kind of
hopeful at the moment.
- Yeah, as my wife,
Sharon would put it,
all government overreach,
all socialism and all other
forms of government overreach,
it always starts out under
the auspices of an emergency.
And I think that's
the awful truth
to which the American
people have awakened
over the last two years.
They've realized,
oh my gosh, if they can
call something an emergency,
they can do anything they want.
And when government can
do anything it wants,
and the people
fear the government
rather than the other way
around, horrible things happen.
So yeah, I think
that has created
a number of accidental
Conservatives and Libertarians
in this country,
is they've seen that
horrible abuses of government
as it goes unquestioned,
all onto the auspices of,
well, this is necessary
because of an emergency.
- What do we do about
organizations like the CDC
and the FDA?
I mean, they're not
legislative bodies,
but in essence it seems
like they legislate.
And then they, it seems like,
well, you just turn
on any corporate news
and they're all sponsored by
Pfizer, sponsored by Moderna
as they're doing stories
on Pfizer, on Moderna.
What do we do about that mess?
- Yeah, it's a great point.
And by the way, I talk
about this a fair amount
in Saving Nine.
That's why I like
to say Saving Nine
is not just about
the Supreme Court,
it's not just about
court packing.
It explains all of the maladies
that flow inevitably
from court packing,
and flowed from FDR's
court packing threat
back in the 1930s.
As a result of that,
we've got too much power
that's been moved from
the people to Washington,
then within Washington,
too much power that has been
voluntarily relinquished
by the people's
elected lawmakers,
and handed out to unelected,
unaccountable bureaucrats,
people at the CDC, and the FDA,
or the two that you mentioned.
You noticed of late it's
been getting worse and worse,
as the Centers for
Disease Control
is a whole lot more about
the control than the disease.
And the FDA, rather
than just looking out
for protecting the American
people from unsafe products,
is all about controlling them,
controlling even the information
to which they may gain access.
This is the predictable
foreseeable,
and I believe avoidable result
of Congress outsourcing
the task of legislation.
We have for decades
had a Congress that's
in effect saying,
we hereby declare that we
shall have good law in area X,
and we hereby delegate to
Commission or Department Y,
the power to make
good law in that area.
And then they get to make
the law and enforce it.
That's a recipe for tyranny.
- So going on the assumption
that there will be a COVID two,
or another version
of something this,
or as your wife would say,
something else that will
scare us in the future,
what actual authority
does the CDC have?
I think that was
one of the things
that really confused people,
that every day, someone
from the CDC will en ski,
or one of these people
would get up there,
they would say something and
then people automatically felt,
oh, that's what they
said, we have to do it,
but that's not exactly how
this thing works, right?
- It's not exactly how it works,
but there's enough
legislation on the books
that gives these government
agencies, including the CDC,
at least a colorable
claim to the authority
to dictate how much
of our economy runs,
that they can get by
the initial smell test.
And see, not everything
gets litigated.
That's another point
I make in Saving Nine,
not every dispute,
not every question
about constitutionality
goes to the Supreme Court.
Most cases don't
even get litigated,
the very small percentage
of those that get litigated
make their way all the
way to the Supreme Court.
And it can take months
or sometimes years
to get to the bottom of
some of these problems.
In the meantime, a lot of these
disputes have become moot,
and the courts then start to
lack jurisdiction over them.
That's why we need
genuine deep reform,
where we withdraw the authority,
the delegated authority
to make new law.
It's one of the reasons
why I believe so strongly
in the need to pass
things like the REINS Act.
Look, if I were in
charge of Congress,
and I had just one
legislative measure
that I could pick and
guarantee passage of,
it would be the REINS Act.
The acronym is R-E-I-N-S,
stands for Regulations
from the Executive
In Need of Scrutiny.
To make a long story short,
it says that we're
not going to allow
unelected unaccountable
bureaucrats
to make our laws anymore.
That will be done
only by Congress.
And when an executive branch
agency uses delegate authority
to create what is,
in effect, a new law
that will not be self-executing
after the passage
of the REINS Act,
it will require an
affirmative vote by Congress
to pass it into law.
You see, people can fire
their elected
lawmakers periodically.
You can't fire a
government bureaucrat,
that's why we need
the REINS Act.
- Yeah, that's also
sort of related
to something else
you said before
about how our system
is different than
the British system,
and yet in some ways we kind
of yearn for more control,
it's a weird paradox
that I think humans have.
I mean, you hear it all the time
during presidential elections,
what I'm gonna do the
first day in office.
And it's like, well wait a
minute, you can't do that much.
You're not supposed to
be able to do that much.
But then they do everything
by executive action.
I mean, I assume that's another
one that you've feel like
has really just we've
let it out of the bag,
and now it's out
of control, right?
- Yes, it's not just that
we've let it out of the bag,
Congress has now blessed it,
Congress has ordained this
as a legitimate law
making exercise.
You know, I keep two stacks
of documents in my office
in the Senate.
Well, one stack is short,
it's a few inches tall,
it's usually a few hundred,
sometimes a few
thousand pages long.
It's the laws passed by Congress
during the previous year.
The other stack,
currently 13 feet tall,
it's often approaching, if
not exceeding 100,000 pages,
and it's last year's
federal register.
That's the accumulative annual
index of federal regulations
as they're proposed, measured
by height, weight, volume,
word count, economic
impact, you name it.
The executive
branch bureaucracies
create more law every year
than the people's
elected lawmakers.
But my copy of the Constitution
in Article I Section One
and Article I Section
Seven make really clear,
you're not supposed to be
able to make a federal law
without Congress.
- So how do we clear
out some of that?
How do we clear out
some of that brush?
How do we get rid of
that bureaucratic state,
or the deep state or whatever,
or maybe not even get rid of it
because some version of
something for stability
has to exist, but how,
it seems like it's just
getting bigger, right?
We talked about
draining the swamp,
maybe there was some
degree of it under Trump,
but it certainly
seems like it's back
and bigger than ever right now.
I mean, is there, do you have
any levers at this point,
does anyone that
cares about this stuff
have any levers to do anything?
- Well, they do only insofar
as the American
people demand it.
And once they demand it,
it will become inevitable
that it will happen.
That's why I think the best
single thing we could do,
I think the agenda
that Republicans
ought to be running on
is passage of the REINS Act,
because that would
force a rebalancing
of this balance of power
between the executive
and legislative branches.
Too much of the power
has been given over
to the executive branch,
that's why we become
vulnerable to all this stuff.
I mean, let's take, for example,
one of the worst abuses
I have ever seen,
of executive power
that's ever existed in the
history of our Republic,
and that was President
Biden's vaccine mandates.
Perhaps the most
egregious among them
was the one that
affected the most people,
a hundred million people or so,
the so-called OSHA
vaccine mandate,
where they
arbitrarily determined
that any employer with
more than 99 workers
had to require vaccination
of all their employees.
And that any that didn't would--
- Wait Senator, are you
telling me that's not,
are you telling me
that's not science?
95 and then to 99, I'd have
to look at the science here.
Are you telling me there was
something not scientific?
- There was nothing
scientific about it,
the virus isn't that smart.
The virus doesn't
have the ability
to differentiate
between workplaces
with more than 99 workers
and those without.
And the Biden administration
wasn't smart enough to realize
it's not within their
Constitutional power to do that,
but they led claim based on
this statute that created OSHA,
you know, or the executive
branch bureaucracy
in charge of
occupational safety.
And OSHA promulgated
using this broad statute,
giving OSHA the power to
make workplaces safer,
this emergency
temporary order saying,
we find this is necessary,
therefore make it so.
That's exactly the kind of
thing that does violence
to our Constitutional
system of government
and separates the people from
their own form of government.
Things like that
have to be repealed,
and the best way to
start that ball rolling
is to enact the REINS Act,
which again would make it
so that any new substantive
change to federal law
would have to be affirmatively
enacted into law by Congress.
- Are you ever amazed
that nobody gets fired
from any of these organizations?
I mean, two years after
COVID, as far as I know,
no one really at
the CDC got fired,
nobody at the FDA got fired.
You know, nobody involved
at the governmental level
who were pushing mandates
that either were illegal,
you know, potentially illegal,
or at the very least immoral,
the series of other things,
you know, they forced
doctors out of work,
and then, you know, first
they were essential,
then they were out of work,
all of the nonsense
that they did,
but I don't know that
anyone got fired.
I don't know of
any other business
that could operate this way.
- Right, but why
would they get fired?
I mean, this is a
feature, not a bug.
This is exactly what
progressives want.
Progressives want to
empower and encourage
that kind of thinking.
So of course they
didn't get fired.
Look, they won't get fired,
they won't lose power
until the people demand it,
and Congress acting on
the demands of the people
relieves them of duty.
- When Judge, oh gosh,
I'm thinking, Mizelle,
I almost forgot her
name for a second,
and everyone should
know her name.
The 35 year old Trump-appointed
federal judge in Tampa,
when she reversed the
airline mask mandate,
I had just started my book tour.
I was going on like
two days later,
so I was gonna be
on a lot of planes.
I was as thrilled as anybody.
And what was amazing to
me was that the next day,
virtually I would say 90%
of people if not more,
ripped their masks
off, you know,
a week before Fauci
had just said,
"Oh, we're reviewing it again,
but we're gonna extend it."
He had just extended the
airline mask mandate thing.
But meanwhile, there's
been no outbreak of COVID,
you know, no new sudden
surge or anything like that.
And all of the people,
we ripped it off,
and everyone was smiling again,
and talking on planes
and at airports,
restaurants are packed again.
This is the type of thing that
I think makes people crazy.
It's like, where was this one
brave woman two years ago?
Where, did you talk
to any judges and say,
"Hey, somebody could do
something about this."
You know, I know you can't
exert influence over them,
but did you talk to anybody
over a scotch somewhere in DC
and say, "Hey, you
could flip this thing".
- Well, I talked at great
length to the media,
to my colleagues,
to executive branch personnel
over the last two years
about the fact
that it was wrong,
about the fact that it was at
best a stretch of federal law,
and acting on a federal law
that should never have
existed to begin with.
But that's the thing
about our judicial system.
They can't just go out and act,
it's one of the
things that I explain
in chapter one of Saving Nine.
The courts aren't just
a roving commission
to smack down things
they don't like.
They've got to wait until
an actual ripe controversy
is brought before them,
a dispute over the
meaning of the law.
And it can take a
significant amount of time
to find the right plaintiff,
for that plaintiff to come
forward and present a case,
and for the appropriate
motions to be made.
And Judge Mizelle happened
to be the first one
to act on one of those,
and I applaud her for it,
it was a correct ruling.
- The book is Saving Nine,
Senator Mike Lee, as I
said at the beginning,
you're on the short list
of sane people over there,
so I wish you luck.
- Thank you.
- My pleasure.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our Politics Playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.